my name is Rafi love and I really wanted
to like again I have the pleasure of
being over here for the second year in a
row opener so we'll start with something
light not too much code and a little bit
about myself I'm a lead data scientist
at Deloitte in our federal cognitive
practice where I really cross over
multiple agencies and a little bit of
commercial I also I also the art
champion for Deloitte federal so
everybody everybody in around agencies
and the work that we do around our I'm
involved to a degree what I really
wanted to talk about today is in a way
continuation of last year so if last
year the conversation was really around
the components in order to being a to
develop a solution the different LEGO
pieces and when you try to develop a
solution and a solution is to me is not
I felt I developed a graph or I develop
an analysis but rather something enter
and scale that a client those are the
people I'm working with can really
utilize to make decisions so that's
really what this is about so I wanted to
take it one level lower to a more
practical aspect I'm a practitioner I'm
everything that I work on Rd or whatever
has to have a business sense to it
otherwise have no I'm not getting paid
so in that regard I'm what is they I
wanted to talk about how you can utilize
essentially Google and a cloud to really
get some additional data additional
information in order to support the data
that you already have or the decision
that you already have in order to
develop a solution and we'll go through
or for practical use cases and this is
again this is not a discussion about
cloud or api's mark is going to talk
about this later today but this is more
of a okay you can Google
how to do that but what do I need to
Google and not just Google stack oh well
so this is really about the third bullet
points over here really about the data
inputs to you model and going through
those I really want to focus for a
second around what is the current use of
cloud so we all know about scalability
we all know about compute I want to
develop a shiny I can put it on a shiny
server I can put it on AWS you just be
etc and I can deploy it to a client
great but really where we seeing a lot
of work right now happening is really on
the fourth aspect which is really I have
an on demand a capability that I can
deploy and this is really a modeling
capability this is somebody already did
some of the legwork for you so how do
you use that
in order to make your life a little
easier and really allowing you to get
someone at some insight from that one so
I'm gonna spend the next roughly four
minutes on each use case and really give
you an idea of what's happening in the
marketplace and how we utilizing are in
order to achieve all of that we'll
really start with one of our biggest
work right now in the state of Kentucky
and politics aside really there is a
there's an effort around trying to
support a individual low income
individual need social help how do we
support individuals like that in
providing them with social services now
there's a very famous a Kaiser research
saying most people and I challenge all
of you most people don't even know what
social services are available to them
especially on the lower end of the
spectrum you know if something happened
you don't even know what I look and
other people especially in the older
population don't even know how to Google
that kind of stuff so how do we nudge
individuals in order to get what they
need so we worked on a website that a
little cell force that actually allowing
people to search for that one
get through the second how do we use
Google it provides individual again in
the foster system a veteran's etc to
start looking for resources that might
be available to them so you can really
start from here and then you get to the
point where you actually can connect to
a resource and these are the type of
resources that are available address
with success or that kind of a resources
now how do you know what to look yes you
can do a search but there's a better way
to do this so one of the things that
we're working on is really around
providing individuals with a suggestions
a nudge in the right direction so we
want individuals that don't know about
something hey by the way there's also
this that you should consider based on
your information based on what I know
about you and I know about this about
you from multiple sources and and I can
have that in that really aggregated and
you can get into clustering analysis and
all that stuff but really what's cool
about this is that I can like Amazon
provide with you provide you with some
related resources I can provide you with
complimentary resources now how do I
know what to give you so we really start
with our capability we are thinking
around people like you also look at
something if somebody else so I would
say listen I'm not going to make any
determination but I'm saying you are
like you and therefore you should also
consider something else and I think all
of you know where I'm going with this
one it's like the Amazon case especially
a complementary and complementary if
people like you really should be
considering the other things so and this
is more of a knowledge base approach so
where do we get into the Google and are
in all this this is a classic case where
I can actually utilize and this these
are the the model similarity and
complementary and this is where we
getting into the use of data enhanced my
data based on current activity on the
website so we all know about you can
google and
I'm sure we all know that Google track
everything that we do but you can
actually use this for good and how do
you do this because I can actually
recognize users and I can recognize
their path around the system and around
the website and I know who those people
are and I know something about you and
therefore I can kind of chart this for
all of them and this is where kind of
this is where we practical use case of
our there's a great package actually
there's couple packages that this one is
using Google Analytics are which is
really an API entry to are from Google
Analytics and this is really where
allows you to take information out of
the behavior and again the code is up
there it's pretty nothing I'm not gonna
go through much into code but you can
really see how you can start getting
information how people navigate through
the system and because they navigate
through the system like that I can now
create Association rule I can create
clustering etc etc this is one use case
that behavior can actually not be a
behavior can not other people behavior
another use case is really around
prioritization there are efforts around
agencies if an agency in how to get I
have limited supply of resources of
people what they need to do inspections
of from the FDA inspection and this one
is around transportation how do I get
from the inspection prioritization done
right they're limited resources
this is what I know about what's
happening around there's a lot of
statistics around that but how do I use
that in order to prioritize now I'm sure
all of us kind of thinking ok well you
get all the data you build some patterns
you build a you can create a different
type of analysis and start graph and all
that etc which is all good and great but
there is an additional path that we are
thinking through and how to really chart
out additional data into your analysis
and one of the things one of the way to
kind of think through that is through
animation and there will be a talk later
on about the history of ggplot2 and
around a descriptive statistics but what
really important over here is two things
one you can actually access google map
and really that like start visualizing
within are the patterns that actually
happen now yes we can have a column for
when things happened you have a date and
you can design a column that creates the
lag but when you actually visualize that
and what you see in the give over there
is really and this is just a really
really small subset accident if it's red
it means there was a human event over
there the size of the dot is obviously
the damage but it was really interesting
over here and you can note you can
notice that it's hanging out in a
particular location it's kind of moving
from Euston it's going up and then it's
hanging out over there for a couple of
days so you can start visualizing that
there is a break in the in the data now
you can visually you can kind of
thinking about why for example
weather-related okay now I know I need
to bring this other data so this is how
this kind of analysis enhance your a
enhance your analysis next use case that
I'm actually encourage all of you to
really explore the GCP and the NLP
capability and this is really around the
api's that we'll discuss later is really
voice-to-text
and this is really if you remember a few
slides ago are talking about the fourth
column of utilizing existing algorithm
and really providing it to you to create
a a speech-to-text
algorithm yes you can do that but you
need massive amount of data it's really
useful to utilize API and and the
amazons the Google the Microsoft of the
world that actually invested in that and
yes there is a cost associated with that
but the important thing over here is
that you can start taking calls and in
this case this is a prison use case
where you can really utilize and
identify if there are any risks
associated
with a particular cold this is not in
order to monitor people and what they're
saying but really do I even need to
worry about this is really around public
safety and in order to know there's no
way to do this manually but how you can
do this using using Google is really you
can start passing it through the API and
get that and here's some example around
50 calls and the word error rate that we
calculated and you can see that overall
we're getting a really good accuracy
it's over it's roughly 70% accuracy on
our calls and you can start building
models around a machine learning model
this is an extra boost model that really
can start a extra boost on top of acting
books but you can really start analyzing
and utilizing the text but it's not just
the text what Google gives you is really
just who says what when you can start
getting the text you're getting the
confidence you getting what it is about
you can start analyzing if there are any
a lexicon that you need to account for
which you can start really working with
the it's not just I have audio and it's
not just text is the combination you can
start calculating for example if I have
a significant break and if I have a
significant break that is important to
me because now I know that somebody's
trying to communicate something unlike
on unintentional or intentionally of
that I don't want them to listen to and
really what it looks like and this is
really again this is all generated in R
this is all it's a shiny dashboard
actually that you can start visualizing
through the API that you get who said
what when you get the the the language
you get the wording you get the the
timing and then tune are you can
actually utilize that to create the
frequency and they in the speed and
essentially the audio component and
putting it together is really where you
start okay now I have a complete data
set and this is just again another
example we can utilize services that are
beyond the mule local laptop in order to
create data sets we have
formation about people we have
information about the coal or just a
high-level date time etc but what you
can really get out of Google and out of
services like that is really the
capability of aggregating additional
data that now give you a complete
picture of what's going on and once you
have this complete data you can add
other data to it in our case and just
want to just a word about that you can
start creating additional you can start
adding additional statistics zero
crossing rate for example which is
really the change of speed now you know
who said what when you can imagine how
you can really incorporate the speed in
which people are speaking if they're
taking a large break or not only then
only then when you have this entire data
set together you can start that's where
the the machine learning that's where
the data sets really applicable to where
you can use that again this is a really
a great use case of I'm not gonna
develop a model that I know that I mean
yes I can develop my own a
speech-to-text model we actually did
that we got a really nice results but
nothing like the googles of the world
and then you can start thinking about a
class security etc but that's a
different discussion and I want to
finalize this with a a really
interesting a really interesting use
case that we built for a banking
institution and there will be a later on
discussion in the business school and
the whole hour of this but the how do
you take a process which has variation
within the process you have documents
like the one on the left which is an
audit report how do you take that and
really automate that so we all you know
heard about robotics and and and and a
natural language processing but there
are aspect of it that you need to solve
that the God is in the details right how
do you solve the nitty-gritty how do you
take a document like that and really
transform that that
code can start making decisions does it
have what I'm looking for it did was the
report states that the auditors may
comply with the particular standards
that the numbers matches what I have on
my own ledger etc etc so these are a lot
of like needy greedy essentially
automating the boring stuff that
individuals are doing right now but
theoretically you can test for them now
then the the the example over there from
the audit report that's nice right
that's a really clear document it's
digital you can read it no problem but
the problem is that it doesn't always
look like that and it's not always
looking it's not always in English there
are and this is actually I was trying at
the bottom right over here you have a
really nice table but you can see that
there are dual lines over here
underneath couple of them and no lines
and others how do you adjust for that
some information like on the top right
you have a lot of a noise in the system
for lack of a better term the one on the
top left is almost unreadable so the
problem that now you're facing is how do
I solve for an OCR problem where I know
my data might be wrong but I do need to
make a decision over that so there are
multiples way to approach that and we
can have a whole discussion around OCR
including a document enhancements and
you can do neural network or Andy trying
to a get a better results of that etc
etc but one cool way to do this is
really around getting the data in
building a corpus of Correction
so why another thing that you can do is
enhance your text saying in my corpus
and this is actually not computationally
extensive it's I can take my texts my
corpus and I can run it through a hand
spell or etc that really can identify a
misspelling and then what what you can
do
is you can scrape google now this is an
example of the front and there is an API
for this as well but I really wanted to
show a piece over here from our crawl
and curl a package over there where you
can really start doing it in the front
end and this is just as an example that
you can get you can spell DCR conference
wrong and using this type of tech code
which is essentially taking essentially
taking what Google says that I'm
actually looking for something and
scraping the website identifying within
the string and then it's turning it to a
string manipulation and what's nice
about this is that you can do this in
multiple languages and really create the
text the corpus correction for your data
that then you don't have to process
every document through a neural networks
and all kinds of fancy schmancy think
that takes compute compute and takes
time to correct an e SC to an E and vice
versa and a particular wording if you
know that this is a common issue in your
data sets you can create that and really
this will take a second I and it's this
this is kind of like a walk around but
this is where Google is really powerful
and you can see at the bottom right
there are some examples over here where
we actually there's a comment in our
corporate common issues and in the
correction that really took place and we
know that this is in our corporates this
is not a right word but we know that
what's the right word now is now I have
viewed them yeah you don't want to do
that but if you have thousands of
thousands of those that's when it
becomes valuable so those are just
multiple cases now you know what to
google of utilizing external sources and
Google in particular to make you
database datasets more complete to make
decisions thank you
[Applause]